depuis des semaines les urgences
débordent mercredi le tour d'occupation
des civières était de 132%. une des
solutions c'est la création de clinique
d'infirmières praticienne spécialisée
merci au dernier préparatifs avant
l'ouverture prévue ici jeudi à partir de
jeudi 1er décembre si ça vous allez
pouvoir
nous voir là les infirmières
praticiennes Nadine Belloni est l'une
des trois infirmières qui vont lancer
les activités elle le fera en plus de sa
tâche régulière dans une autre clinique
nos frères du temps supplémentaires
volontaire pour pouvoir commencer la
clinique elle fera du temps
supplémentaire ici pour soulager ses
collègues dans les urgences c'est
d'ailleurs le principal objectif de
cette nouvelle clinique tester un modèle
et surtout d'enlever de la pression sur
nos équipes dans nos salles d'urgence
vous voyez l'état de nos salles
d'urgence surtout dans business au
niveau de l'hôpital Maisonneuve-Rosemont
l'hôpital sainte-agabriniospedale alors
c'est sûr que tout ce qu'on va pouvoir
offrir va enlever la pression des
patients des urgences de l'Est de
Montréal pourraient être référés ici ces
infirmières praticiennes spécialisées
peuvent diagnostiquer plusieurs maladies
et même prescrire des médicaments
le patients qui se présente pour des
infections urinaires
presque tout le matériel médical était
déjà sur place c'est que les infirmières
remplacent des médecins qui sont partis
à la retraite c'est un ciel C qui a
connu une baisse d'activité dans les
années passées alors c'est sûr que c'est
une façon pour nous de redonner de la
vie à ce si elle laissait au départ on
verra ici 250 patients par semaine deux
autres cliniques d'ips ouvriront à
Montréal d'ici février ici David gentil
les radios Canada Montréal